we just posted Our World Cup toy hype  tape and I wanted to point out some of  my favorite little details that you  might have missed for starters erling  Hollins locked up in this toy package  called the eliminated collection he's  one of the best players in the world  right now but Norway didn't qualify so  sorry early then we get Neymar balancing  his boot on his head in reference to his  legendary Sally a few years ago and we  of course had to throw on maradona's  famous hand of God incident where he  handed the ball to give Argentina the  lead over England in the 1986 World Cup  quarterfinals the English are still  pissed about it does well it was his  hand and the men still haven't won a  major trophy since 1966